qual o problema do mundo atual mais
incomoda e mais indignada em dia
aquele programa que toca o seu coração
que você gostaria de ver resolvido no
mundo
qual é vai pensando nele um pouquinho
que daqui a pouco te conto qual é o meu
desde muito cedo fui uma criança que
queria fazer as coisas diferentes de um
jeito diferente e isso fez de mim uma
adolescente super questionadora super
defensora das próprias idéias e super
definição daquilo que acredita
eu sempre fui muito apaixonada por
natureza e isso fez desde muito cedo com
13 anos que eu queria ser bióloga
eu achava que a minha contribuição para
o mundo ea vida por meio do cuidado com
a natureza
ela era uma das pessoas que falavam que
gosta mais dos animais do que das
pessoas sabe mas com o longo do tempo
foi mudando e acho que eu fui evoluindo
e quando terminei a faculdade há seis
anos atrás eu sabia que não era esse o
caminho que o saque ea verdade é que não
dá pra mudar o planeta
segundo as pessoas e eu comecei a
entender que a forma como a gente se
relaciona com a gente mesmo e com os
outros
tem tudo a ver com alguns padrões que a
gente observa na nossa sociedade e com
muitos dos problemas que a gente está
enfrentando a forma como a gente enxerga
o outro como a gente escuta o outro e
como a gente se conecta com ele tem que
mudar
se a gente quiser construir um mundo
mais pacífico mais sustentável e mais
colaborativa pra todo mundo e daí então
compreendendo que toda transformação
passa pela gente e que a nossa mente tem
muito poder
eu resolvi que queria estudar como é que
o nosso cérebro funciona
e aí eu fui estudar neurociência e
dentro da pós em neurociência o tema da
empatia veio pra mim como meu tema de
estudo quase como uma intuição e não
sabia muito não sei muito bem explicar
porquê
e naquele momento eu ainda não tinha
noção de todo o potencial da empatia e
não tinha noção de que esse pm a vir à
minha causa e é transformar todo e mudar
todo mundo da minha carreira
na verdade eu nem tinha noção do quanto
esse tema é importante pra mim aquela
adolescente super questionadora super
defensora das próprias idéias como se
fossem verdades absolutas
e lá fui eu estudar sobre empatia essa
não
a capacidade de se colocar no lugar do
outro de adotar sua perspectiva ou seja
chegar o mundo pelos seus olhos e
compartilhar seus sentimentos e aí eu
fui descobrir que a empatia real na
verdade quebra vários dos nossos
paradigmas
sabe aquela regra de ouro que a gente
aprende desde que a gente é criança faça
aos outros o que você gostaria que
fizessem a você esquece a partir de
agora ela não vale mais
não faça aos outros o que você gostaria
que fizessem a você
ele simplesmente podem ter gostos
completamente diferentes dos seus
a empatia tem a ver com entenda isso
sabem empatia aquele sentimento fofinho
amoroso materno que tudo aceita
vamos muito além desse conceito a
empatia é uma força poderosa a empatia é
o elo que une todos nós como sociedade
a gente pode até achar que a sociedade
do jeito que está agora não é a
sociedade que a gente queria viver eu
posso garantir para vocês que sem
empatia a gente não está vivendo em
sociedade nenhuma
a empatia é uma força revolucionária que
pode ajudar a gente a transformar esse
mundo que a gente vive num mundo que a
gente quer viver realmente são tempos
difíceis para os sonhadores e nesses
tempos difíceis às vezes não é fácil
falar sobre empatia
às vezes a gente é levado a acreditar
que o ser humano não há empate com a
natureza
muitos historiadores escritores
filósofos escreveram sobre o lado ruim
do ser humano lado maquiavélico egoísta
e a gente pode estar sendo levado a
acreditar é a nossa sociedade está
levando a gente acreditar que esse lado
pode ser maior e mais forte do que o
lado bom ser humano do que o lado
colaborativo generoso e eu não vou negar
que os acontecimentos que a gente vê por
aí todos os dias tanto na tv nos
noticiários ou até mesmo coisas que
acontecem no nosso dia a dia podem
confirmar essa crença podem fazer a
gente achar que o ser humano é um ser
egoísta mas é aí que entra a ciência
para trazer um pouco mais de esperança
pra gente porque a neurociência tem
feito muitas descobertas sobre como ser
humano funcione sobre como agente
relaciona e essas descobertas
tudo pra gente uma nova visão do ser
humano então pra começar a neurociência
já comprovou que nós somos seres
simpáticos por natureza
nós somos seres sociais são somos feitos
para vivê e se beneficiarem sociedade
equilibradas
a gente nasce com estruturas processos
conexões cerebrais que existem para que
a gente possa se conectar e expressar
empatia sabe ea gente começa a
manifestar isso desde que a gente é o
bebê
sabe quando você pega um bebê e fica
fazendo uma careta pra ele e de repente
ele começa a imitar essa careta você
fica fazendo um som e de repente ele
começa a imitar seu som
esse bbb thati me tango ea empate ea
limitação é uma das bases neuronais da
empatia é porque a gente pode imitar o
que a gente pode enfatizar isso é
possível porque a gente tem um sistema
de neurônios especiais chama sistema de
neurônios espelho que tem a função de
reproduzir em espelhar no nosso próprio
cérebro qualquer coisa que a gente vê no
outro pode ser uma ação pode ser um
movimento pode ser uma emoção a gente
observa se no outro e é como se
estivesse acontecendo na gente
é por isso que eu pedi pra todos vocês
agora imaginar em um quartinho no meio
do dedo aqui assim feito com uma folha
de sulfite e uma gotinha de limão caindo
em cima dele
eu fiquei observando algumas caras ea
reação é é sempre colhe você faz um
barulhinho evita que nesse momento o seu
sistema de neurônios espelho está
funcionando e é como se estivesse
acontecendo no seu próprio corpo
é por isso também que a gente chora em
filmes tristes é por isso que a gente
pode de alguma forma
sentiu que o outro sente porque é o topo
que a todo momento a gente se espelha no
outro
segundo lugar a neurociência mostrou pra
gente que apesar da empatia sem nata ela
pode ser treinada e isso é possível por
conta da característica mais maravilhosa
do nosso cérebro na minha opinião nosso
cérebro é plástico
isso significa dizer que ele se molda e
ele se adapta a todo e qualquer estímulo
que a gente dê pra ele
é por isso que a qualquer momento da sua
vida você pode aprender qualquer coisa
nova
você pode aprender a falar nós
um novo idioma tocar um novo instrumento
musical ou desenvolver qualquer
competência que você quer desenvolver e
que a empatia é exatamente a mesma coisa
se você resolver a partir de agora
exercitar sua empatia de forma
consciente o seu cérebro vai começar a
desenvolver estruturas específicas vai
começar a criar novas rotas naturais e
vai fazer com que ao longo do tempo a
empatia pra você seja um processo cada
vez mais automático natural tão legal
assim a mostra pra gente que a gente na
simpático e que a gente pode é exercitar
nossa empatia
porque né porque a gente vai gastar
nosso tempo exercitando a simpatia
em primeiro lugar acho que porque
ninguém ninguém vive sozinho nesse mundo
ea empatia pode sim ajudar a gente a ter
relações mais profundas e mais
significativas com as pessoas ao nosso
redor
em segundo lugar porque hoje a empatia
já tem sido considerada uma das
principais competências do futuro uma
das principais competências da liderança
do futuro porque ela nos ajuda a
desenvolver outras competências muito
importantes
a empatia ajuda a gente a ser mais
criativo mais inovador e tem um
pensamento sistêmico muito mais apurado
mas consegue olhar por um problema não
só sobre o nosso ponto de vista mas sob
vários pontos de vista diferente
a chance da gente achar uma solução para
ele realmente efetivo é muito maior e no
mundo que está vindo aí cada vez mais em
rede cada vez mais conectado cada vez
mais colaborativo
eu acho que essas competências são
fundamentais mas vou falar de novo a
empatia vai além disso eu perguntei pra
vocês no começo
qual o problema do mundo te incomoda
mais
aqui a gente tem um mapa de alguns dos
problemas do mundo provavelmente o
problema que você pensou ataque
se ele não tiver depois me falar que eu
vou inserir então guerras desigualdade
pobreza ea intolerância machismo
questões ambientais a gente tem muitas
questões no mundo
a gente começa a analisar a gente quando
vai perceber que esses problemas eles
não são isolados uns dos outros
eles são todos sistêmicos e
interconectados e se retroalimentam o
tempo todo e eles apesar de diferentes
eles têm algumas coisas em comum eles
têm algumas causas em comum e eu não
tenho dúvida que a falta de empatia
é uma causa comum a todos esses
problemas ea gente pode aproximar por
dois pontos de vista pelo ponto de vista
negativo é a gente pode até ficar
paralisado com ele né fala putzke
negócio complexo que eu vou fazer para
resolver um mapa desse tamanho como é
que eu vou resolver tudo isso
ou a gente pode olhar pelo lado positivo
lado da solução e pensar assim
a ênfase à falta de empatia na raiz de
todos esses problemas
então dá pra gente imaginar que a que o
desenvolvimento da empatia pode ajudar a
gente a resolver todos os problemas e aí
eu queria trazer um conceito diferente
que é o conceito de ponto de acupuntura
na medicina chinesa os pontos de cultura
são pontos do nosso corpo que concentram
grande fluxo de energia e que a ativar
aquele ponto você não está resolvendo um
problema específico você está aliviando
o sistema inteiro
quando a gente tem sistemas muito
complexos como esse que a gente não
consegue atuar em todos nós
a gente precisa buscar pontos de
acupuntura se você mexer naquilo que
você mexe em tudo e eu acredito muito
que a empatia é um dos principais senão
o principal ponto de acupuntura da nossa
sociedade que precisa ser desenvolvido e
olhando pra isso eu descobri que esse é
o meu problema é o problema que tira o
meu sono
a nossa crise de relações a nossa falta
de coletividade como é que a nossa
conexão ou não conexão com algumas
pessoas chegou ao ponto de causar esses
problemas
como é que pode que algumas relações
estejam tão frágeis chegam ao ponto de
gerar guerras conflitos violentos
causados pela intolerância
isso não pode acontecer e esse virou a
minha causa resolveu exibir ou o tema do
meu trabalho e desde então eu tenho
tentado levar esse tema
essa visão mais ampla da empatia com o
maior número de pessoas e tentar plantar
uma sementinha de empate em todas elas
assim como eu tenho um monte de gente
por aí fazendo isso usando empatia como
inspiração para a transformação social
para mostrar três exemplos muito rápidos
existe um ep de ponte inter só que não é
só pra que relacionamentos amorosos e
pode fechar migos aqui também se conecta
pessoas que estão em lados opostos de
conflitos políticos
o que esse ep faz além de conectar
israelense para china os republicanos e
democratas é aproximar pessoas produto
que realmente importa o que elas têm em
comum e não que ela sente diferente às
vezes a empatia pode inspirar também
experiências realmente transformadora o
teto ele é uma ong que promove o
desenvolvimento de comunidades muito
carentes
pelo meio do teto jovens normalmente de
classes mais altas passar alguns dias
emersos numa comunidade carente
construindo uma casa para uma família
eu fui voluntária do teto um tempo e eu
posso garantir que muito mais que a
entrega da casa
a conexão que existe entre essas pessoas
essa experiência e essa vivência tão
profunda de empatia transforma você um
jeito que nunca mais você vai ser o
mesmo depois de uma experiência como
essa não tem mais como olhar para a
pobreza e desigualdade da mesma forma e
às vezes a empatia pode até inspirar
revoluções na tecnologia
esse é um projeto da onu de realidade
virtual
então a onu tem criado esses filmes em
realidade virtual que já coloca um
óculos e você sente como se você tivesse
lá
por meio desses filmes você pode viver a
experiência de uma criança em um campo
de refugiados sírios ou pode conhecer um
centro de tratamento de bola na áfrica
pelos olhos de uma de uma enfermeira
voluntária e apesar dessa experiência é
uma experiência virtual
ela é extremamente visceral e ela também
fica com você como se você tivesse
estado lá e eu fico imaginando o
potencial desse escala imagina se todas
as pessoas do mundo pudessem se conectar
dessa forma com gente que elas nunca vão
encontrar na vida e mais do que isso
imagina se todos os governantes do mundo
pudessem antes de tomar decisões
importantes
passar por experiências como essas viver
a realidade dessas pessoas eu tenho
certeza que as decisões seriam
diferentes
esses são só alguns exemplos de gente
que está usando empatia como fonte de
inspiração existem muitos muitos outros
tenho certeza que vão passar vários por
aqui e todos esses exemplos são na
verdade revoluções revoluções pacíficas
e sistêmicas estão mudando o primeiro as
nossas relações
para mudar aquele sistema todo depois
nesse processo todo desde que eu comecei
a estudar empate alguns anos atrás eu
tenho aprendido algumas coisas com os
workshops que eu tenho feito com
conversas que tenho tido com pessoas que
enxergam empate de forma diferente e com
o processo de transformação que tem
acompanhado e eu queria compartilhar 3
das intenções
a primeira delas é que a empatia de amor
em cada um de nós e ela já faz parte da
nossa vida a gente não estaria aqui
vivem em sociedade se não fosse ela e eu
fico pensando se ela já mora em cada um
de nós ela já faz parte da nossa vida
porque a gente não está exercitando ela
mais a gente se preocupa tanto em
desenvolver tantas competências
profissionais coisas que a gente acha
que não é importante para a nossa
carreira e talvez a gente esteja
esquecendo de uma das competências
pessoais mais importantes para o mundo
hoje em dia
segundo lugar eu aprendi que sim a
mudança começa dentro de cada um mas
isso não é o suficiente isso não basta
a gente precisa que cada pessoa
transformada saia da toca e vai pro
mundo levanta do sofá e vai pro mundo
criar novos projetos novos movimentos ou
pelo menos inspirar novas pessoas que a
gente não muda o mundo sozinho mas a
gente principalmente não muda o mundo só
olhando pra dentro
a gente precisa olhar para fora também e
por fim e mais importante é muito
simples começar o primeiro passo é muito
fácil
cada pessoa nessa sala nesse exato
momento pode começar a revolução
cada pessoa pode assumir o compromisso
de adotar um novo hábito por uma
sociedade mais simpática e por relações
mais simpáticas não depende de ninguém
só depende de cada um de nós e se a
gente tá o tempo inteiro esperando que a
gente vê no outro os nossos neurónios
espelho permitem que a gente faça isso
será que ao fazer isso a gente não vai
está inspirando que outras pessoas
também assumam compromissos por novos
hábitos mais sustentáveis
acho que sim e mais gente estiver
caminhando e adotando novos hábitos mais
simpático será que a gente junto não vai
caindo em direção a uma sociedade mais
pacífica mais sustentável e mais
colaborativa eu acho que sim eu acredito
muito nessa revolução da empatia e eu
sei que o caminho é muito muito longo
mas eu acho que quanto mais gente
acreditar nela junto mais rápido a gente
chega lá
obrigada
[Aplausos]